bella tutti ragazzi oh cavolo aspetto
dimenticata musica che va
ecco a posto della tutti ragazzi e
prevenuti questo video sono fa dj ed
oggi siamo in loro superlativo bloccarla
ragazzi prima di cominciare come al
solito ripartire con l'iphone app della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta dal non mi ricordo un nome però è
[ __ ] c'è ma è [ __ ] la fan arte di capite
male è una bomba vera ogni e bellissimo
complimenti a chiunque abbia fatto
questa cosa ah allora solari passate le
cose serie questa settimana qui sto
preparando una parodia io non ho mai
fatto una parodia ma ci tengo che venga
da theo uscirà prima del 28 febbraio
perché deve essere candidata all'oscar e
devo portarlo via a di caprio attrezzi o
un messaggio che ho ricevuto questa
settimana da marrakech che a far
marracash è un rapper per chi non
conoscesse che ha fatto un singolo è
praticamente mandato un vocale e sarebbe
questo o per una volta nella mia vita
per la prima volta è l'unica sono
riuscito a superare tra vige un idea non
è vero comunque meritato zio perché il
pezzo veramente una figata pazzesca che
tatro niente canzoni d'amore era questo
pezzo era veramente figo quindi li
capitando dall'ascoltare complimenti
marras
allora ragazzi queste questa cosa questo
tubetto di dentifricio si chiama crystal
ball è una cosa che andava un sacco
quando quelli della mia generazione
erano più piccoli poi si spalma per me
ne soffre poi si soffia su quello che
all'apparenza può sembrare un
preservativo gonfio e la crystal bomber
che ve lo sto facendo vedere che cosa
mica centra essere umano non ha mai
capito a cosa mica servano le christabel
fatti zag ombra più nessuno però non
potete capire quanto questa cosa abbia
fatto parte della mia infanzia
i ragazzini di una volta nelle pipette
cimentavano solo il crystal ball non le
cagate che ci sono quindi fate i bravi
non fumate se vi viene voglia fa cagate
fatevi una cristal bob cone che ragazzi
c'è una cosa che volevo assolutamente
fare siamo arrivati al momento clou e da
un sacco di tempo che mi chiedete di
pubblicare un video di file del canale
non ho mai messo in realtà ragazzi sto
preparando un video enorme di file
oppure di scene particolarmente strane
dove cantò perché io per prepararmi
video canto e se per caso sto giocando a
un horror e più horror la parte in cui
canto che il gioco stesso con dispiacere
che non avete idea perché è mio mi
vergogno di faccio finta di non sapere
cosa state per vedere è veramente uguale
ognuno
[Musica]
facciamo entrare il grandissimo sfidante
di turno che si fanno farò un taglio
insegnami a giocare non sono ancora
aperto io quindi non so neanch'io
ascoltare lui e mio papà
c'è lo dico perché tanto vabbè cazzo lo
dico a fallimenti di questo ne sono
tanti
dai su un lavoro ma non c'entra scusarmi
non ami
se non è un foruncolo merda non esplode
perché inizio e capelli de merda
solo se questi dischi ma ci vediamo al
prossimo vito bella ragazza
complimenti per la realizzare mai 3 2 1
sto per lanciare adesso lo lancio bene
ma merda lanciare lo faccio io da
ragazzo sta bene e lo fa papa ancora
baffati ciao
vabbè
lasciamo perdere anche ragazzi possiamo
solo perdere se uno scatto dei pacchi
che è meglio i ragazzi ho mandato che
padre a prenderne uno nel garage dei
valori spero che ti piaccia ci ho messo
tantissimo impegno bike.it grazie kiki e
complimenti per la scelta del
dell'incarto perché lo stesso tipo di
incarto che usava mia nonna
usalo mentre i tuoi dormono o mio dio ma
rob e stelle filanti manolo zia si può
provare a sfruttarle a mio padre di
notte sarà era assurdo cos'è sta roba
ma siccome ragazzi non so se sono pacchi
da essere umano faccio che aprire questi
perché sono lanciato lo più perché che
cazzo me ne pò animale ad animale
domestico perché questo quindi devo dar
da mangiare c'è una roba da vita propria
vabbè lasciamo perdere per ora allora è
questa cosa qua questa cosa qua mi ha
fatto appena a cagare addosso la mia
nuova ragazza
grazie pensavo fosse la testa vera di
una persona deve voleva essere un prank
sei riuscito ma bene anche un pupazzetto
co queste beh questo è bello e mondi
hammond e slip vero ricordiamo in the
slip neri passare all'ultima ragazzi che
è leggermente grosso melo ma potevi
attaccarne un po di più di figurine anzi
faccio che farlo io proprio quello
faccio io è una roba seria tra l'altro
zoda c'entra un cazzo però attacco zola
giusto perché ce n'era un po che sa bene
che ci sono un miliardo di carte di
figurine alla madonna va bene che è
bellissimo questa è una parrucca no non
so cosa state pensando non lo farà se mi
inviate un'altra parrucca faccio
concorrenza wheelus che palle cup è come
non sono fatte per i capelli voi donne
quindi ragazzi non faccio il fa vi
risponde perché sto preparando una roba
per quanto riguarda infatti risponde che
vedrete nei prossimi blog non ce la
possono fare domanda come cazzo vivete
coi capelli bar [ __ ] come fate voi
donne a vivere quei capelli lunghi
e così che non vi siano in bocca ai
ragazzi invece chiedo se riuscite a
trovarmi un nome per il mister che ci
sta guardando con lo sguardo sexy ed i
ragazzi concluso qui i blog spero che
vide vi sia piaciuto a cava senza vita
più sul documento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come nei video
trovate nella descrizione siamo sempre
stati i civili da un po sorrido capelli
che sono stati nella bocca di fa vj 800
euro
beh ragazzi